all right hi my name is Colette you bozo
it's great to be here I'm a suicide
attempt survivor and I'm really here to
share my story about hope and resiliency
and also that while I'm not sure that
life necessarily gets better but you
people get better and I just want to
like let people know that it is
preventable
there is hope hi my name is Kris
goldsmith I'm an Army veteran I work for
Vietnam veterans America and I run a
small nonprofit called high ground
veterans advocacy what my small
nonprofit does is I train veterans to
find their voices va released a report
just the other day about 20.6 veterans
dying by suicide every single day among
active duty Guard and reservists we're
losing 3.6 per day I was one of those
back in 2007 almost I luckily survived
my suicide attempt after returning home
from Iraq and at first it was it was a
big struggle the army interpreted my
suicide attempt as an act of misconduct
and for that I was kicked out of the
Army with what's called the general
discharge there are five hundred five
thousand veterans in this country right
now who've been kicked out of the
military without benefits many of them
after having served in combat dating
from Vietnam to Iraq and Afghanistan now
in Syria I've spent the last decade of
my life advocating for veterans and for
the general public I mean the problem
that we've seen in the veteran community
right now is reflect as a reflection of
the poor mental health care services
that we have in this country there's a
tremendous shortage of mental health
professionals and despite all of our
work there still remains the stigma
against people who actively sought help
I'm struck by the misconduct I want to
get back to that Desiree I'm very stage
I created a project in 2010 called live
through this it's a series of portraits
and stories true stories of suicide
attempt survivors across the United
States I've interviewed
185 suicide attempt survivors in 36
cities and what I've learned in doing
that work is that suicide doesn't
discriminate people who have attempted
suicide come from all walks of life and
it's really important for me that that
people see that because I think we need
to really change public attitudes around
suicide and that's that's why I'm here
and why it's important for me that's why
we're here to to change public attitudes
miss Lisa and I run a Family Foundation
and I'm a mom and I wanted to do this
because I promised myself after
surviving that if I could save even one
person from feeling the hopelessness and
the fear of coming out with depression I
would do whatever it took in in my
situation I was the one that was always
happy and carried everyone and so there
was a certain stigma of letting everyone
down
that was counting on me that prevented
me from getting help and it's so
important to me now to communicate that
having help is the most amazing thing
that asking for help
surprisingly or not surprisingly you'll
find so many people are feeling the same
way you are
and the healing goes both ways mm-hmm I
like that the human goes both ways
certainly last but not least Gregg I am
I live with bipolar illness I had for
most of my life
I've lost my my birth mom to source up
my grandmother the suicide and I'm a
three-time attempt survived and got to
the point like Lisa said and I promised
myself the same thing you know I figured
after three times those who can't do
teach so I thought I'd get into advocacy
and if I could stop one person from
suffering as I suffer and feel the way I
feel to me I could probably then die in
peace
and it's me it's very important because
to me there's a missle misnomer about
suicide suicide is not a disease suicide
is not a disease suicide is an event
like anything else mental illness is a
disease same as cancer same as diabetes
same as any other disease it's not
understood because you can't see it you
can't feel it and it's not it's not put
up as mercy and angels that you know we
can save someone from cancer we can save
some and people don't understand you can
save people from mental illness and from
from taking their lives
can you save people Greg I'm very
touched that you would share your story
you should know that we're all here
because we do want to learn how to be
better and do better so the fact that
you're sharing your story as painful as
it is I know will help a lot of people
but what is it that we don't understand
what we don't understand is that people
with mental illness are not monsters
they are not different okay they are not
people that you wouldn't want to
associate with be friends with and that
stigma
separates us from the rest because there
are people who still think that mental
illness is a weakness and not an illness
okay I Know Who I am now
this person there's two of me there's
one inside and there's this do you see
suicide as a mental illness no I see
suicide as a as a completion of a mental
illness that cannot be or has not been
addressed nor controlled it's a symptom
it is right it is a symptom I agree with
that wholeheartedly I look back at the
point in my life that led me up to
suicide I had spent a year in Iraq from
ages 18 to 19 my job involved
photographing of mass graves I saw dead
children on the side of the road
inexplicable violence that that violated
the very core of my humanity and it
haunted me in ways that I couldn't
understand and I didn't have the
vocabulary to describe when I reached a
point while I was still in the army and
I realized that I needed help it was
already too late for me by the time that
I finally saw my first doctor after
suffering for over a year with
post-traumatic stress disorder after I
came home I had already been declared as
is cleared for deployment medically
cleared it didn't matter that once I was
medicated that I had been talking about
having issues of feeling suicidal
to the army at all at that point they
didn't take me seriously and you went to
them for help I did and they didn't take
you seriously what did you say I that
you know I had lost purpose in my life I
had lost control of everything there
there was a thing a policy called
stop-loss while I was in the Army it's
kind of a backdoor draft the end of my
contract had had been about to expire
and because they needed more troops in
Iraq they involuntary extended my
contract I was headed to instead of to
college I had applied to college back
back here in New York and accepted to
multiple schools fully prepared to
become a civilian again and then because
of the troop surge into Iraq in 2007 I
was stuck and it it took a long time for
me learn how to say this but attempting
suicide was an expression of control
over my own destiny because I had lost
everything else and it wasn't until I
got out of the army that I went to the
VA and I was finally diagnosed with PTSD
while I was in the Army I was diagnosed
with depression anxiety disorder I had
been medicated none of that seemed to
matter to the army but the VA saved my
life it took about five years where I
was in a dark pit of depression you know
to be honest I can't remember a lot of
it because I was drinking so much at the
time I've lost my early 20s to
alcoholism a depressant depression
mm-hmm
but there was a team at VA who genuinely
cared about me and that's what I needed
I needed that human touch
I live about 20 miles away from from my
VA in Long Island and I anytime that I
drove out there because I was feeling on
the edge again they would make time to
see me and to sit down and talk and it
took a long time but that's it was
tremendously helpful the human touch it
is interesting to hear you know one of
the reasons we're here is the
back-to-back deaths of Kate Spade and
Anthony Bourdain and I think for many
people when you heard that the country
was shocked to hear that two seemingly
successful happy people both of them
parents had taken their own lives in the
way that they had taken their own lives
I think was sort of jarring to a lot of
people at least I'm struck by the fact
that you said one of the first thing you
said was I'm a mom and I think what so
many people are wrestling with when
people make the decision to take their
own lives is how could they do that to
their children how could they leave
their children behind is that the wrong
question for us to ask absolutely you
are not you are not in any way thinking
that way what are you thinking in in in
in in my mind and in my case I was
seeing how my life had spun out of
control how a perfectly seeming
successful person with beautiful kids
and everything to live for and I
couldn't function is the ages of your
children yeah no three are 13 17 19 and
22 mm-hmm but I was the mom that I like
a lot of us was going to bed and at 2 3
o'clock in the morning I just could not
stop crying I was I was alone and
fighting depression undiagnosed so as it
became more difficult to function harder
to leave my house the anxiety increase
you know simple things like I didn't
open my shades you would come into my
house and you would say it's so dark in
here
and and I didn't know how to reach out
and so when I saw that I just was
hitting bottom and I thought of the
burden I was going to become to my kids
the loot because of the least amount of
stuff that I could do that's when it was
rational to me that they would be much
better off without me so in your mind
you weren't leaving them you were
actually thinking you were burdened to
them and that they would be they would
be in a better situation that they would
because at the time you were thinking it
seems it seems rational you have all
these reasons you have all these reasons
why in my case I also got sick with a
condition that had no cure and at that
point I it was like I've got depression
I'm at that point I had a feeding tube
it was everything it's like the perfect
storm came together and to be a bigger
burden to my kisses seemed completely
unfair but at the end of the day it's
it's not you're not doing it to somebody
you're doing it because in your mind you
believe or in mind that it it was in the
best interest of everyone and after you
survive Lisa what is your thought oh no
I'm still here or thank God I'm still
here I you know those first few weeks
are like a blur I think most people was
saying that it there they're a blur but
then it became oh thank god I'm here
because there there is a solution there
all of a sudden there were all these
resources and people and you didn't know
about that before no I did not know no
and so I was I was able to you know the
in my in my case the crisis center in
the town I live in
you became my ultimate Saviour they they
they saved my life
they they taught me they helped give me
the tools that I now today say I live a
a happy life I mean
every day is not a happy day but I live
a happy life because of the resources
and tools they gave me and I'm able to
pass those down to my kids they you feel
so alone and it's so embarrassing and
even doing this is difficult because
you've the backlash that you know to be
perceived as weak and in corporate
America it's it becomes difficult but
this this this allowed me a second
chance to really make a difference and
and I learned to love myself yeah
ecology I see you shaking your head when
she said because it's so embarrassing
well I just I really feel connected to
that piece I was very embarrassed when I
was going through and it's an ongoing
struggle still still but when I was when
I was younger I was feeling suicidal and
I didn't know that I shouldn't talk
about it so I talked about it and I
ended up going into psychiatric hospital
it's terrifying like they take away your
shoelaces
it's like these bright lights I don't
know what prison is like but I think it
might be like that and the experience
that I had from being in the hospital
was so traumatizing and but tell me what
was going on in your life at 14 that you
felt this was probably a better way out
at 14 yeah I think one of the things
that happened was you know you've said
this and many people say suicide is a
permanent solution to a temporary
problem well the problem for me was that
my grandmother and I have a lovely
mother who's wonderful my grandmother
came down and helped raise me and when
she died of cancer she wasn't coming
back
that wasn't a temporary problem like I
couldn't actually imagine a world
without her she believed everything
should be a desert she took care of my
Tamagotchi she was just this wonderful
bright woman and I could do no wrong and
it wasn't just one single thing that was
it was like an event of I feel really
low self-esteem I don't think I should
be here
love myself and then the trauma of her
dying I was like well what's why is it
worth it being here so I can't say that
it was one thing but I know that that
kind of sped me forward to that well
tell you is that when I left the
hospital I pretended that everything was
okay I was like I will do anything not
to go back there if that means stuffing
down these feelings of hatred of myself
of like no self-worth I'll do it because
I don't ever want to go back there was
so scary
so I spent years pretending everything
was okay putting on a mask because it is
embarrassing
and then when I'm like in my early
twenties like something happened where
that mask had to break and I attempt it
again and and before the attempt I
actually went to get help I went to a
hospital I said you know I'm having
these thoughts of suicide but because I
present well so I I went up there like
you know I'm really having some
challenges and having thoughts of
suicide they looked at me like you're
fine because I was able to articulate
that I was having challenges and I'm
pretty sure it's also because I'm a
black woman and there's a way that I'm
strong or I present in a way that oh
nothing is wrong with you
and so I go in there and they release me
like the next day meanwhile in the
actual hospital I have I they're
actually showing silence of the lands
like this is the kind of care we're
getting and like part of me laughs
because that's so ridiculous and the
other part of me thinks of like what is
this care this is why I avoided the
hospital because I wasn't going to get
help there and that was in my situation
I have to use I statements so it's not
everyone's experience of that but once
that I once I was raped I didn't want to
be here anymore
and I just I just didn't want to be here
anymore and I it took a really long long
path it took me into health advocacy it
took community it took being part of
this an incredible documentary the S
word that follows a lot of suicide
attempt survivors and tells our stories
but my goal is to advocate for real
change I don't want anyone to be in a
hospital
like the hospital I was in that would
have people running out
no like that is the exact opposite and I
want to help people understand that you
know when people are sick like in a
hospital you bring them casseroles you
you you bring them flowers you give them
cards I don't think suicide should be
different when someone's suffering
I think it's connection that keeps us
here so the moment that you can't tell
anyone because they're gonna judge you
or say that you know what you're doing
is selfish or that you're a bad person
well that just keeps them from not
telling you so you have a whole bunch of
people really presenting well looking
really good on the outside and so alone
because they don't want to tell anyone
that secret and I think secrets keep us
sick and I don't think that secret helps
me secrets keep us sick Desiree we don't
always know that people are suffering
we don't even know sometimes people the
closest to us are suffering it's suicide
is rooted in despair and isolation and I
think those are those are human
conditions and that's why it's so hard
for me to understand sometimes why
people don't get it because pain is pain
when you say they're rooted in despair
and people feel alone you'll look at
people that that seem to have a healthy
relationship they have a great job they
have a family that they know loves them
but yet they still go to a really dark
place and I think that's what most
people are trying to figure out how does
that happen
yeah like Lisa said every everything
looks fine and you want to be there for
everybody but it suicide and those
thoughts just just turn you inside out
you you go you go inside to a place that
you just don't feel like you can share
that with people because you why-why
feel like your autonomy could be taken
away you feel like people are gonna
think that you're weak or you're selfish
or that it's going to go on a permanent
record I remember having that used
against me when I was also yet the
record that follows you around your
school record did somebody tell you it's
gonna go on give an example of that I I
wanted to be a psychologist so I
followed that that track in academia for
a while and when I had my suicide
attempt
said you have to get out of the hospital
do whatever you can because this will go
on your record and I did that and for a
lot of people that probably would have
been a bad choice to get out of the
hospital in the way that I did for me it
was a good choice I had a great support
system took care of me and I would be
willing to say that my best friend saved
my life but that's not the case for
everybody not everybody has a great
support system and some people can have
good experiences in the hospital but I
did have that used against me it'll go
on your record and it's like there's
this fear because it's like I just lived
through a suicide attempt because I
thought I didn't have a future yeah and
and now my future could be being
threatened even further that's that's a
really scary place to be and Greg you
said that you had tried more than once
that you tried three times and there
there's a history of suicide in your
family do you think that there's a
genetic component in your case or you
just think that it's just the bipolar I
think it's a combination coming I you
know they're doing so so much research
on the genetic aspect of mental illness
if it's passed down I'm not really an
expert in that if you've tried three
times
how do people close to you know he's
okay now
how can they ever feel comfortable
knowing they don't they don't they don't
and what should they do
my own family doesn't trust me to this
day it's okay to not this is normal it's
okay to not be okay it's okay to not be
okay I mean there there are people all
over the world who are not okay and
sometimes it's a lifetime condition
sometimes it's temporary you know we we
don't have to pretend to be strong all
the time no and you know and that's why
we're all here it's okay to show show
your vulnerabilities you know and I wish
more people would do that do you worry
about being judged once you show your
vulnerability I did at first but I
you know it just pasts my 11 year alive
date a lot of veterans have in a live
day yeah after having been shot or blown
up in my case my alive days surviving a
suicide attempt and that was
embarrassing at first but in keep
meeting people like this from
generations before me I learned that
it's okay it's okay to be proud that
that you survived it's okay to be proud
that you made it past that and it's okay
to fall back into it too you know what I
what I learned in in my survival is that
I had the capacity for survival and that
I had the capacity to use my voice to
help other people out of it and I mean
that's what this whole thing is about
today mm-hmm is showing people that you
know you can move past it I 11 years ago
was in a horrible depression I was an
alcoholic I had just been released from
a mental health ward today I'm a student
in an Ivy League college I am an
advocate speaking out on behalf of one
of the nation's most respected veteran
service organizations I've started my
own nonprofit you know I've been to the
White House a few times I meet with
members of Congress regularly to talk
about my own suicide attempt this
administration is is still learning
about the mental health issues that I
think we're all learning happening to
this to be honest with you I really do I
think so so many people are just thrown
by it and sometimes it takes a very
public well known figure for people to
go what in the world is going on I'm
wondering Lisa what did you say to your
children
I had one who would not my oldest
daughter was was the one who dealt with
the fallout of my situation and use the
word fallout well she was the one who
made the phone calls and had to she's
the one who knew oh my god my mom's my
mom's gonna be gone what am I going to
do and she's the one who had to pick up
the phone and make all the phone calls
and and find the mom so what I what I
was not able to - there was nothing I
could say to make her feel better she
had to literally process it on her own
in her own and ended up writing a song
about it that that expressed and once
she was kind of past that it took about
six months before she would actually
speak to me because she there was anger
she was she was angry my other three
kids I was able to sit down with along
with a therapist and was able to
communicate to them that this was in no
way shape or form their fault and that
they were the best part of me because I
would think as a child if your mom tries
to take her own life you would certainly
blame yourself and they did yeah and
they did and so we we we definitely had
it's it takes time it's like anything to
work through it I'll say now five years
later our relationship is the best it's
ever been and we're all advocates
they're advocates from the the being the
the family going through it and me from
having gone through it but I still have
to drive home the point to my kids that
my situation which is major depressive
disorder is a chemical imbalance and
what happens it's not on them so they
could there's no needing to be perfect
there's no needing to not let my mom
down it's not about them and so it's
a daily and I think everyone would agree
that depression is a daily you wake up
and you make a decision that today I'm
gonna get through today still everyone
feels that it is suicide a chemical
imbalance I can't say that I think
suicide is a chemical imbalance because
I know people who have never received a
mental health diagnosis who you know
might have lost a job or a traumatic
event happens that causes them to feel
like they don't want to be in this world
but I you know I think it's I think it's
one of those things that we want to do
is not label all of the experiences
because if we say oh it's because of
mental health or oh it's because of this
one thing you know we would have to be
very careful because there are many
different reasons there's many different
reasons and there's many different
solutions it's definitely specific to
people I think the thing that makes it
connected is actually connection is what
heals us but why we go through it how we
got here I have to say it's very
different for each person every person
like I used to believe in a chemical
imbalance and now I'm like maybe it was
trauma it was I experienced trauma and
you know that was something that
happened because when I was in a
traumatic moment I was right back to
being attacked and I wasn't I wasn't
driving the bus I was just like I was I
was not all there but you know and maybe
that's PTSD maybe it's this maybe it's
that but really the important thing is
to know that like suicide impacts many
families many people it's not just us
and we keep saying that we are you know
we don't have to be strong but I think
asking for help and coming out and
saying this means that we are strong do
you know how many people don't ever
share this because it's scary you know
we are sharing this because we're strong
enough to stand here and say you know
what it is a sign of strength to ask for
help it is a sign of strength to look in
the mirror and say I'm gonna try to stay
here that's a sign of strength I'm
trying to figure out guys and I like
Chris how you jump in everybody feel
everybody feel you don't have to wait
for a specific question if you want to
make a comment well I'd like to make a
comment on
what she just said she's right she's
right not hiding she's right that not
all suicide is is completed by people
who have mental illness that itself is a
stigma because that the public can say
well it's only the nuts that do this the
normals don't and that's not true at all
there are people that take their lives
that are not suffering with any kind of
mental illness yeah like she said major
divorce happens a husband leaves a wife
leaves whatever it is it could just be a
life event that triggers some sort of
something in some it's more public
health issue than a mental health yeah
yeah so so people have to understand
that this isn't just a mental health
issue let's not just make it that but we
come from a lot of us from the mental
health because this is what this is what
I'm trying to understand guys what is
the difference between we all go through
something that's very jarring to us
what's the difference between someone
who just powers through and someone else
that just says I can't take it anymore
I've got to go is there an answer to
that Desiree I think we all have a
different capacity for pain and our
ability to withstand it you know what
what could be life-threatening to me in
terms of suicide could be your Tuesday
and we're just all very different people
you know my in my story I was in a
physically and emotionally abusive
relationship and then there was this
breakup and I was in the transition from
college to grad school and they don't
tell you when you graduate college and
go out into the world what's gonna
happen next that's a really scary place
to be and all of those things happened
and I did have a diagnosis I have been
depressed since those 14 years old all
of it came together and it was just that
was the day that I I I couldn't do it
anymore or I thought that I couldn't do
it anymore
and like Lisa said earlier when I when I
made that attempt that was that was when
I realized that that I wanted to be
alive like I
it took me attempting to realize the
value of my life which is a shame but
are you always you sit here today glad
you survived
do you still struggle with it every day
like I could do it again are you all
really glad that you survived it's both
for me I'm really glad that I'm here I'm
really glad that I stay so I guess I say
that it's I'm happy to be here and the
thoughts are still there but I have a
different plan this time I actually have
a safety net to help catch me I heard
guys about that everybody or many people
have a safe plan I have a safe plan I
would be curious to hear what is your
safe plan you know what they what my
resources taught me was to have like a
core group of six people and only those
six people that I interact with and they
received a safety plan that basically
says if these things start to happen if
you see these symptoms if I'm not
leaving my house if I'm not returning
your phone calls if you your texts go
unanswered for you know days at a time
if you know if you see me overly happy
or appearing to be overly happy those
are symptoms that you need to reach out
and ask me how I am and so in the event
these things happen here's some of the
things that would help me you know get
me to do opposite action if I'm sitting
at home and tell you I don't want to go
anywhere invite me to get my nails done
and say I'm coming over
don't don't make it like an optional
thing I'm coming over we're gonna go get
our nails whether you want to or not
right do you have a safe plan Chris so
my fiancee is someone who although she's
not a vet she spent two years in
Afghanistan as a civilian contractor and
she is also the editor of at war for New
York Times and we have both been
surrounded in veterans and advocates and
we're very lucky to be educated about
this I I feel like the veteran
population despite our higher rate of
suicide is actually lucky because for
years we've been aware of the suicide
problem among the
population and we've been exposed to a
lot more resources I as a veteran
qualify for VA health care you get the
best mental health care at the VA in the
entire country so I almost feel lucky
because I'm surrounded by people with
safe plans we don't have to discuss it
they all know the the symptoms that you
just described are something that is
second nature to us so you don't
necessarily have or need to say because
you already have it never something that
I've needed to express because my
fiancee would would notice in a second
what's hurting anything Lauren we like
her already
Greg do you have a safe plan III really
the only plan I have is when I wake up
every morning I find a reason to live
that day that day that day
it's literally day by day not tomorrow
not yesterday that day this day what was
your reason today to live to be to do
this to do this and to save lives yes
while you're doing it exactly well
that's one right now you are saving the
whole the whole point to me if any time
I can think or know and feel that
somebody will see this and they'll say
if he can do what I can do it and then
we'll go get help and they won't be
Oh [ __ ] your paper so my safe plan is
just simply that well you know what why
do I want to live today what's good
about today and and and it gets easier
now I do have I do have a chemical
amount and there are just days that it
takes over and and my my my yoga mentor
has taught me you are not your illness
you have a chemical imbalance and you're
gonna think certain thoughts based on
that but that's not you is you okay
helped you yoga is probably I would say
the main tool I have found that keeps me
alive and it's not asana it's not poses
it's not going to classes its philosophy
I've become a student of yoga philosophy
and reading the the Sutras of Patanjali
and it has given me a whole different
outlook on myself which I then see the
world differently so yoga could be
helpful for you but may not be helpful
for you Desiree do you what is your safe
plan make jokes about yoga all the time
and how it's not helpful for the long
list of the coping skills
what is your say is so helpful but not
for me
my plan is less formal you know I the
the person who attempted suicide at 23
and the person I am now at 35 they're
completely different human beings I have
a beautiful perfect life now I have an
amazing wife I have a new son I have I
created a job out of the ether doing
exactly what I want to do I've been able
to interview 185 people who are just
like me and I've built a community out
of that for me and for them
and so when when things get hard for me
and they do I've had several suicidal
crises lately and this month is honestly
a really bad month for me historically I
haven't been doing the best
I'm not having suicidal thoughts but I'm
depressed so when it comes down to it I
just tell everybody I'm like hey it's
not awesome today I mean you know how
they say on Facebook specifically people
only share the best parts of their lives
yeah I shared the good and the bad it's
like a picture of my baby and then I'm
having really terrible thoughts it's
3:00 a.m. I can't sleep you know it's my
whole feed looks like that and for me
it's just about this kind of radical
honesty and when it gets bad I just hit
my red button and go it's it's bad scent
cats you know so people check in on me
yeah that's and cats yeah and its it
holds me accountable and and then my
friends can also help me and it also
kind of teaches people how to talk about
it yeah and speaking of talking about it
because I think sometimes we're thinking
well I don't want to talk about it
because if I ask her how she's doing or
ask him how he's doing that'll just make
him feel really bad and then I could
trigger something should we ask you
should we go and talk to you about it
what should we do yeah and I I will say
what's worked for me but I also want to
say there's a myth out there that if you
ask someone if they're suicidal that the
it will trigger a thought of suicide
that's not true so it's not contagious
it's not contagious it's not a cold if
it was the thought wasn't there you're
not gonna make it there you're not
planning it if it was you're not
planning it there and I think what
people tend to do because they're afraid
to say you're not thinking about doing
something stupid are you yeah and then I
now know that you think that's stupid so
I'm not going to tell you that I might
not tell you the truth so it's really
actually really like hey you seem really
down have you had thoughts of harm are
you okay do you want to go for a walk
yes and some people weren't great at
talking I have a lot of friends when I
was going through my last mental health
crisis they all took different roles the
one who wasn't a talker was like you
know what you haven't left your house in
a couple days let me get you groceries I
don't know how to talk about suicide but
I can get you food I had another friend
who went on walks with me someone to
talk with me I had it as simple as four
people sorry foreigner you have
different folks doing different things
yeah is it as simple as people just
really showing up and getting in your
face because we may think we're imposing
for me I think it's showing up because I
had a friend who's like you're not
responding to my calls so I'm coming
over and I was like oh dear and in the
moment I was not happy about it but
later I was I was like oh you see me I
can't put on a mask with you know the
line you just said you're not thinking
about doing something stupid I've heard
people say they don't think we're trying
to make light of it though you know
people don't understand what it is they
don't understand it it's got that
negative connotation to it it's you're
killing yourself you're you're leaving
your family behind you you know you're
quitting your job you know all these
negative connotations so why would you
do something so stupid yeah and that's
not helpful to hear you really think if
it was just I'm just stupid that I'm
gonna do something like this people
aren't thinking about the paint they're
not people don't understand that and
it's been proven that if somebody would
compassionately ask somebody not not say
you're not thinking of doing some stew
you're not thinking of killing yourself
are you see are you thinking of harming
yourself do you have those thoughts can
I help you
the first therapeutic for all of us is
humanity its humanity not the medicine
not the therapy not the friends not the
family just humanity we need people to
show us and reach out a hand to us to
show that we do matter and sometimes
it's a stranger when your family can't
do it it could be a stranger just shows
you I was at a yoga event last night I
hate to break and I was manning a table
from American Foundation suicide
prevention giving out information and a
woman came up and she's just staring at
me and I said can I help you is there
something I can help you with she goes
yeah I was looking to get some
information I said how can I
help you she said well I just lost my
son a month ago he jumped off the Bear
Mountain bridge at that moment there's
nothing I can say most people would say
I'm so sorry
oh my god to me there was nothing I
could say I came out from behind the
table and I just held and said nothing
yeah and I I let her sob all over my my
shirt it's it's okay to be wrong to to
you know not everybody responds to human
contact to some the same way you know
and if you're good with words use your
words if you're if you're if you are the
total opposite and you don't have words
to use give somebody a hug yeah I mean
they're the only wrong thing to do is to
do nothing taking action in any way even
if that's passing off what you perceive
is a problem to somebody else that's
fine I mean that's what the suicide
crisis line is for you know there are in
my community there are veterans all
across the country who are mental health
first responders who are literally
trained to be the first point of contact
you know what's interesting to me is how
you said just reach out you just want
humanity and I think about the people
who have committed suicide does it mean
they didn't have friends they didn't
have humanity they didn't have people
that care it in their life that's why
that's why I'm so stuck on this you look
at Anthony Bourdain and Kate Spade who
inspired us to talk about this so
publicly you know they were surrounded
by friends and loved ones and they were
rich and for the average American they
look at them and say you know these
people didn't have problems but there
are some people just have demons and and
it's okay we need two distinct idea that
successful people that problem fall
victim to
for circumstances you know I people see
Anthony Bourdain they see Kate Spade and
they say how could they do something
stupid
famous people it's their circle didn't
even see their families from they don't
even see it in their face for a lot of
these people success is not a barrier at
I attend Columbia University our
University has been losing students to
suicide competitive universities have
have got a real big problem right now
with an the stress culture exists yeah
we've been losing students to that and
thankfully these universities are
starting to act but it it's not just
something that needs to happen on the
hyper local level where friends and
family and jobs and schools need to be
aware of what to do our federal
government needs to do a better job of
making sure that people can pursue
psychiatrist and psychology degrees and
not have to worry about crushing debt
for the rest of their lives you know I
thought Lisa you said it well when you
said on the outside everything seemed
fine do you find in all of your cases
did you hide how you were feeling from
the people closest to you I did all of
you hide how you were feeling I
absolutely did a fantastic job
always being on point yeah I was the OCD
mom the OCD CEO oh but see this is what
scares me Lisa if we don't know you're
in trouble how are we supposed to help
you how are your friends and your family
supposed to help you if you all hide all
of this from us if it's not safe to tell
you we're gonna hide it and so like I
don't know what the situation was with
Anthony or Kate but I don't know how
long they were fighting yeah so we
everyone's like oh they took their lives
how could they do this I'm like you
don't know how long they were fighting
those demons you know maybe they stayed
for a really long time but if it's not
safe to talk about it then we have to
hide and I want say we have to hide you
don't make it
to now step out even though I've lost my
job for disclosing that I had a mental
health it what happened telling me that
I was working it was it was soon after
my it was after my hospitalization I
took on a job at a pediatric office and
I was just doing some like clerk work
and the person who attacked me reached
out to me and that triggered me I
started having thoughts of suicide I had
been in these wonderful comfortable
spaces that kept telling me talk about
it stayed open tell the truth and I told
my boss I said hey this happened to me
I've been attacked this person reached
out to me I'm having thoughts of suicide
and she says oh my god Colette she I'm
so sorry that happened to you why don't
you go home why don't you take care of
yourself do you know that I went to work
the next day and I heard her telling the
doctor we have to get we have to fire
Colette she's crazy you heard her she
never say that and sure enough I get off
the schedule somehow they don't need my
help anymore so what I'm telling you is
I had openly shared that and then I lost
my jobs there is a real risk to sharing
this and so I think it's a public health
crisis because of the silence which is
the stigma which causes people not to
share and then hide and pretend and then
die by themselves Colette she when that
happened what did you think when you
heard her after you had opened yourself
up to her like I'm an idiot I can't
believe I told her that but I have a
lovely mother and she's like no this
isn't meant for you you're meant to do
something else yeah so I actually ended
up moving to California go mom mom she's
right she is definitely the best
advocate I could have and she's a doctor
I have I am privileged to have had good
health care and have someone help me
navigate a very complicated Mis office
so I think it's interesting because what
I'm learning is there isn't a one thing
there isn't one specific thing that it
comes in many forms
yeah because because I was so hung up on
but they had everything to live for or
so and so has a chemical imbalance so I
understand that but you know there
really isn't a one-size-fits-all but
there are there are there are signs yeah
what are the signs Greg and and Pete
well
the main signs are changes in a person
behaves see okay even we who mask it and
hide it and that commercial that's on TV
even though it's for a drug for for an
antidepressant I think that's a very
powerful commercial because it has that
woman who has the this met the face yeah
happy face on the stick and she's
walking around behind it she's and the
mask is the happy face yeah and that is
exactly the visual that people need to
see because then you think you know wait
a minute my husband the other day he
kept saying you know what's the point
anymore paying the mortgage what's the
point in doing this was it he doesn't
know when we talk like that that's a
sign when people change their daily
routine in their attitudes and and you
know their interactions with their loved
ones with friends you know that's a sign
you know I used I was an avid golfer for
years one day I just took my golf clubs
in the garbage I never play golf again
and nobody saw that as a sign that just
I wasn't happy anymore doing that so
that's a sign things like that are signs
that we can all learn and that may be
able to have open us a conversation with
the person would save a lot there's any
kind of adversity that you see in
someone's life that's the time to go hey
are you okay how can I help you
breakups I mean that's that's a big part
of when I struggled as a teenager was
breakups and it's well even now anytime
there's a threaten a threatened
relationship that's when that's my big
trigger that's when I get really scared
that's when things get hard for me and
I'm learning from the experts in your
field that it's incorrect impolite and
just plain wrong to say they committed
suicide do you all agree that that is
the wrong terminology to use wrong
terminal what should we say and why is
committing suicide an inappropriate
thing to say anybody would say so died
by suicide or they took their life or
completed a suicide if people say to
learn
words are powerful and they have an
effect on those that hear them to say
that you commit a suit a committed
suicide is similar to you committed rape
or you committed murder or a committed
adultery it's a sin to commit something
crime you know gee yeah what what this
is is suicide is a symptom it's not a
sin it's something that happened to you
the same way that getting hit by a car
happens to you it's it you know for some
people can be just some random trauma
that came out of nowhere unexpectedly
it's a symptom I like that Chris it's a
symptom not a sin and I think they
should also be careful when and I've
seen this written some places where
someone says something like it was a
successful suicide there's no such thing
as a successful suicide or fail
non-fatal right so failed means you
stayed which we don't want to ever
communicate to anyone that's staying in
this world was a failure we don't ever
want to communicate that killing
yourself is successful like we just die
by suicide we think color it committed
suicide about that one like in my work
it's all about changing public attitudes
showing that suicide can affect anyone
and that like like he said it's it's
about the language and how powerful the
language is the words we've been using
are a little too powerful what we want
to do is kind of neutralize the fear
everyone has about suicide so that we
can get them interested in funding it
and helping in some way this is a field
that is severely under populated and
underfunded so if we're using language
that's more objective that's descriptive
and brief they died by suicide that's it
we're kind of neutralizing it we're
moving toward that I mean cancer was a
word that we didn't use in the 50s we
were afraid to say the c-word
now we're afraid to say the S word and
it's just something it's a one one tiny
step toward possibly making the S word
something that we can say and what's
your best piece of advice to leave
people with hope who are watching you
who are thinking I relate to her I
relate to him or what is that
that there are people who are gonna
watch this who have experienced the same
things that that we have and haven't
found a way to express themselves and
they need to know that it's okay not to
be not to know how to talk about it you
know and we were just talking about the
language that we use we are not victims
we're survivors and the people who
helped us weren't just doctors and
friends and and family you know people
call me a hero because I served in
combat I can tell you I didn't do
anything heroic but the people who saved
my life for the Department of Veterans
Affairs the psychiatrists they
psychologists the social workers those
people are heroes here and we need to
start creating more of those heroes in
this country whether that means
subsidizing their entire education on
taxpayer dime now maybe that's something
we need to talk about we need more
heroes and heroes or people who help
people are struggling mm-hmm you know
the statistics show Greg that white men
middle-aged white men and you you would
fall into that category have the highest
have the highest suicide rate black
women have the lowest suicide rate what
to both of you say about that why do you
think that it is Gregor do you I think
actually I don't know I don't know yeah
I I really can't answer the women rate
is going up though the rates are going
on what bothers me as children the rates
are going yeah as young as seven and
eight years old children talking about
and completing society that's what
bothers me I can help you with that Greg
and maybe you've experienced this so I
work for Vietnam Veterans of America
Vietnam vets right now out of the
population of veterans are the ones who
are dying in in the greatest numbers not
the highest rate the highest rate right
now is is young veterans who recently
experienced trauma but the highest
numbers are Vietnam vets who are for the
first time retiring spending a lot of
time by themselves who aren't able to
keep themselves busy because their their
bodies are now we're starting to fail
mm-hmm that's that's why
other people are then it's it's a
cultural thing to expect black women to
be strong and and thankfully that helps
a lot of people think yeah so I have to
say that I don't think the statistics
are right I don't think black people are
actually captured the data yeah and I
think that's the challenge we also have
something I'm gonna say a controversial
but I'm gonna say it anyways there's
something in the black community called
blue suicide and that's something where
people of color antagonize police
officers on purpose to die and that is
suicide but that will never be captured
in numbers I will never be captured in
data and that means our numbers are not
collected correctly so if you don't have
culturally responsive researchers
collecting data on suicide if you don't
have a connection with your coroner's
office who will give you the correct
numbers you won't actually know what the
real numbers are white men are hired
because white men get captured more and
they're also in the system more mm and
there's many reasons why people of color
black people will not go into a mental
health system but that does not mean
those numbers are correct what's just a
reporter mm-hmm had asked me I when
after after the Kate Spade and they
asked me if I would do a quick
two-minute interview for one of her
questions to me was the CDC report
states that 54% of people who complete
suicide commits suicide they said are
not diagnosed with a mental illness well
what do you say to that and I said that
means somewhere between 0 and 54 there's
a percentage of people who have just not
been able to get proper health care to
be diagnosed that and that's been one of
them and when I was getting help that
that was a hurdle that is out there the
insurance companies they recognized
cancer and diabetes and also many other
illnesses but when it comes to mental
health they they put you through the
wringer you have to appeal for your
medication two or three times to get the
right medication you have to
you also point out you don't always need
medication I thought that wasn't I think
that's important for people to know so
I'll close with this what's the question
any of you you wish I would have asked
but didn't did you want to get out there
I just think of it but I just think it's
such an important topic I think the
question a lot of people want to know
the answer to is is suicide going to
affect me and I can say yes it probably
will affect you a suicide a colleague of
mine Julie cero there's a there's a
statistic that we've been throwing
around for years that suicide intimately
affects six people every suicide death
intimately affects six people that is
wrong
Julie Saral came out in 2015 with some
new research it's actually more like 135
people affected by every suicide death
from first responders to friends to
family to it ripples or it's a big wide
now think about that 135 people per side
death and 42,000 suicide deaths every
year and that's not even including
attempt survivors and people who have
had suicidal thoughts this is something
that will affect all of us and so I
think that is what should compel us into
action
learn how to get trained you know learn
how to see the signs fund these
organizations that are so underfunded
help researchers volunteer foster care
crisis text line National Suicide
Prevention lifeline okay I thought you
guys were really good you know before I
came I was talking to experts and they
said you should not ask how they
attempted suicide and I said why is that
an impolite or inappropriate question I
think when you talk when you talk about
suicide you have to report it and I'm a
I'm a next journalist so there's this
desire to know because I was I wasn't
even trying to be salacious I was just
curious about what what why is that not
reporting it's about I think Knology is
not it's been proven to be unsafe and
when when they described on newscasts
how Kate Spade was taken a lot I think
that bothered me to no end no end I
you actually cry because I said why
would they do this
why there can't think of her children
think of her husband think of family
well do you think you can see they hear
this and know that that but do you think
that it gives people not ideas why I
think it's just gives people ideas there
is a contagion I think it's 5% of
suicide deaths are have a contagion
element to that I see but there's also
the fact that it triggers people I read
a story about how how deeply affected
Kate Spade was by Robin Williams suicide
death yeah and we know that Robin
Williams death was covered he knew
exactly how he did it where he did it
what he did it with and Kate Spade did
it the same way and then we described it
again and then we had Anthony Bourdain
and it's like why are we giving why are
we putting this information out there
like why why why make that Gore factor
the important part what about the pain
so great yes
so Gregg are you saying because of the
humane part of the story we shouldn't
report it or because it gives people
ideas it gives people ideas and the
humane a part of the story I think it's
both ways I mean it goes both ways and
it can't you know you know you have to
think of the family I mean doesn't
really want to go home and somebody see
on TV that would I want to go home see
that my wife just shot herself yeah I
wouldn't want to hear that you agree
Lisa I agree and for me it's it's a
trigger asking someone to relive
something that they've worked for you
know a lot of us years on it's it's a
trigger